we had a new type of sorority all of us
will be living together during fantasy
suite we are you getting me some
sexuality it went really well you know
and the non ultimatum ultimatum of the
century it's the black and white
situation this is your bachelor season 9
episode 24 recap grab your glasses it's
time for Rosie's and Rosie oh we're in
the fantasy zoo hi everybody
it's me Lauren Zima and I have one
question to ask you did you get
productive last night it was productive
okay it's fantasy suites guys let's get
to it since it's fantasy suites I have
to bring something up Chris Harrison
sent me a rose a drink today yes he is
launching his own rosette like this is
why we're dating you know so we're gonna
give it a whirl but of course I couldn't
have a blast
without my glass so I'm going to pour
this amazing Seagram's a tropical rose a
with him stuff Oh passion fruit fantasy
suits into our roses and Rose a glass Oh
very light in color perfect perfect a
mountain I can okay mm oh wow I was
actually the first time tried it's
really good you know I love that it's a
can rose a on the go pop it open anytime
you want sometimes you need it anytime
you know watching this show okay but you
know Chris Harrison doesn't do gifts
small so he sent me more than just this
can
[Music]
go big or go home you know we're
beginning where we left off back in the
hangar I'm also wondering how did we get
here I mean really really here because
Peter has his final three but Madison is
saying she's struggling with the idea of
an engagement
I don't think Peter knows how much I'm
struggling with you know moving to the
next level of like the fantasy suites
and engagement
Madison you just accepted his rose why
are you here Oh although I wrote down I
do love her jump suit was cute
I love a jumpsuit anyway if next week
you were to like sleep with somebody
else like go be really hard for me to
like so we find out this conversation
that we've been teased to where Madison
tells Peter that she doesn't want him to
sleep with anyone else actually happened
before fantasy suites and so I'll give
Madison that but the thing is is she
even really saying that is she saying
anything
[Music]
Madison say words I mean don't drink for
all of the undefined statements I don't
know what are you what are you asking no
I'm not asking that I just I don't like
I don't want to tell you like yes or no
no dummy
cheers to Peter for trying to understand
he says so you don't want me to sleep
with anyone if I were just like like
spend the night with someone else is
that something that you could do like is
that a new that's a no oh yes a Meany or
possible it would be any outcome effect
deed you wouldn't be able to keep this
going with me if I spent the night with
anyone else
Madison same words it's just the
communication on this season is why
house isn't as wild as the Australian
outlet on offer we're getting there but
we got to get through this first and
that brings me to our deep emotional
question of the week this might not be
an ultimatum but is it a test like
actions speak louder than words
why is Madison here I don't know why
Madison came on this show how did you
guys feel about this conversation but
now where are we in Australia I'm
dreading this whole entire week as for
where she is Madison says quote this is
a weird this is a weird position for me
to be in well it's the position people
on the show have been in for more than a
decade of seasons so it's actually quite
common watched by millions of people
every week you saw the show right
Madison if you watch the show okay it's
all good and drink for all the awkward
silence because it turns out the women
are living together during family
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving everybody and it is not giving
these women individual hotel rooms
bachelor historians I call upon you but
I believe it to be unprecedented cheers
to that
definitely don't drink for every time
someone says it's awkward awkward
definitely a little you know possibly
awkward so awkward weird this is called
a Seagram's escape and I I want it too
from this Hannah in you wanna go Daddy
yeah and get some one-on-one and it's
nice you know it's a beautiful golden
hour lighting on the golden coast so
they're being passionate and Peter says
he has zero doubts about their
connections zero doubt that I have it
with her 747 she's making my heart want
to come out of my chest and then Peter
communicates something to us the
audience that I think just explains
quite a lot
he says if this is what love is this is
what love is then was this you love cuz
I am gonna what
Peter says I never want to come down
from this and hopefully I never have to
I never want to come down from this
don't say I never asked you Peter I'm
giving you an ultimatum here today
no more 747s
okay pilot Pete okay I never want to
come down from this I think you do Peter
you know I think we're all kind of
free-falling at this point we're gonna
come down you know luckily my boyfriend
made this so at dinner Peter tells
Hannah an another big statement he tells
her that he doesn't want her to worry
about them and I don't want you to worry
not us and this is when the word of the
episode really became as simple as it is
communication because it isn't simple
here the season 24 of the batch there is
it like Peter what does that mean what
do you mean she doesn't have to worry
isn't that telling her I'm picking you
yeah but we're moving forward and they
actually had to the fantasy suites and I
wrote down I really appreciated how
excited Hannah Anna was for dessert
cheers to that Hannah and you never have
to worry about dessert but back to the
Sister Wives house there's a really
funny moment when Madison is talking
about theater and Hannah Ann's date and
she says they're probably getting ready
for dinner and Victoria is like or for
bed they're probably getting ready for
their dinner portion right now we're
ready to go to bed I see exactly what I
have in front of me and it's the most
perfect woman that I have honestly I've
always dreamt of he says Hannah Ann is
the most perfect woman the most perfect
woman great problem solved
leave with her right now I know
why'd you do this to us hi everybody
coming in hot with a quick vlog to
address the tweet that I tweeted and
then deleted and that some people are
now in correctly interpreting as some
kind of a spoiler so if you missed it I
said something along the lines of Peter
just called Hannah and the most perfect
woman in the world how does he not occur
then that was the tone I meant I was
just critiquing Peters as I've called
them all season extreme 7:47 statements
about these women I deleted it because I
didn't think it was that funny and I
thought of a better funnier tweet which
I then tweeted that's all thank you love
you bye
oh but then things get sexual then
things are exciting then I'm escaping
and Peter and Hannah and deliver a
moment we've been waiting for all season
the Titanic has moments we knew knew it
was Hannah and behind that frosted door
it's the
[Music]
you
it's not that sexy what I'm doing it
it's like I'm high-fiving myself in the
mirror we're doing on back and forth
this episode back to the sorority house
and Madison says she's reaching her
breaking point I am so close to like
reaching my breaking point well we all
are Madison so you know just like we've
all seen the show we're all reaching
their breaking points I might need
another case in a minute no I'm starting
to like get super impatient then he had
an walks in back to their joint share at
home they're like oh my god you look so
cute oh you look cute oh my god you look
so tan no let's be honest isn't the real
question is do I look like someone who
just said sex do you have that glow Oh
God drink again for awkward silence
cheers to Hanna Ann's truth she says
quote it's weird we're all still here
it's weird we're all still here right
[Music]
yeah you can say that again
it's weird we're also here right we're
here we're all wondering why we're here
JC doesn't know how we got here Chris
sans not aware of why we're here
but we're here but life's about moving
forward so that one day you can escape
Victoria F is up next and speaking of
moving Peter says quote every time we've
had an issue she has walked away from me
every time we've had an issue she hasn't
walked away from me in that moment but
we're still here but we're still here
we're still here is I out fearing NER I
lost the ability to say words and
communicate because EC Hill don't know
how to communicate maybe the word of the
episode isn't communication maybe it's a
phrase maybe it's still here okay the
passion is 100% there Peter says he
loves victorious fire you know there's
obviously that fire
aka mess I'm actually attracted to that
and things are never going to be boring
it's never gonna be a boring
relationship
aka Hurricane Victoria and he says I
love everything about this except the
community I love everything about my
relationship with Victoria except when
it comes to just communicating how do
you love everything if you don't love
the communicating because how do you
talk about anything if you're not
communicating and how do you engage and
grow together if you can't talk together
and how do you know the person if you
can't know the words they're saying it's
never gonna be a boring relationship but
again moving forward they're talking and
they say that they're so excited they're
not fighting
what's wild about the two of them also
is that they are not even able to
communicate if they're on the same page
about communicating because Victoria
says they can talk about anything I feel
like we can talk about anything
I'm just really about it conveying what
I want to say to him nope that makes no
sense okay
back in summer camp I told Peter that I
didn't know if I would be able to
continue this with him if he were to
sleep with other women
Madison is telling Hannah Anne straight
up that if Peter sleeps with someone
else it's a make-or-break kind of feel
like it's I don't know honestly kind of
like a make-or-break for for me and good
lord cheers to Hannah and again she says
I was thrown off by them I always start
off by that we knew what we signed up
for and then I really got to raise my
glass to our girl because she just
starts calling it all madness
it's truly madness like it's just
madness
she's like this is madness and this it's
kindness it's madness it's madness it's
madness it's badness
[Music]
maybe that's the word of the episode
madness back to dinner with Victoria F
Peter keeps saying that with the two of
them you know when it's great it's great
but it's great it's great and it's on
and I see it and I see that future with
her you know what else is probably great
free floating through space in that
moment you're taking in the inexplicable
masterful power and beauty of our
universe and all things in it how does
it possibly all exist you wonder until
all the breath you sucked out of your
body and you die I feel like we need to
have more of a conversation and then Wow
Wow Wow Victoria f4 finally you guys she
is finally here in f4 fantasy suites
explaining to Peter why she has a
difficult time communicating I know that
you know how I am but I need you to know
why I'm the way that I am she's
explaining she has issues from her past
relationships and I think it all kind of
stems from my past relationship I owe
this and and I'm glad it's happening but
again now here okay I don't know what
you want and then of course things are
turning I'm asking these questions they
generally care I know and shears to
Peter because he does tell her we can't
keep doing this this means to stop us I
know this is why I said many episodes
ago that Victoria F needs to work on
herself before she can be in a healthy
relationship yes your partner should
help you grow yes
your partner should support you as you
work on your flaws but Peter is not her
therapist
okay he can't fix all this you know and
definitely not here
there's too many candles it's a
different vibe we're still on the dinner
date and Peter tells Victoria if he
doesn't want her to push him away but I
do I do you guys I want her to put him
in a boat and I wanted to push that boat
offshore and as Peters traveling on that
boat
I want other healthy relationships to
join him and for him to have beautiful
dates with those people in that boat and
then back on land
I want Victoria F to learn about herself
you know experience things experience
people and just focus on her and growing
who she is what she's passionate about
that's not what I have to say I'm kind
of sad for Victoria F because she's
crying and saying she loves Peter
[Music]
there's so much
and again what is love
this is what love is we don't know in
the show back at the girls locker room
and wow drink every time Madison
contradicts herself you know I think
it's a black-and-white situation of
hearts full or heartbreak she now says
this is a black-and-white situation well
you didn't tell Peter that like I don't
want to tell you like yes or no it
Peters living in shades of gray buddy
and not fifty of them because that would
be sex stuff and you're not doing that
that's fine don't tell him that okay in
the morning after Peter and Victoria
hooked up right I mean drink every time
they say it without saying it you know
I'm so good
last night took our relationship forward
in more ways than one we're so connected
now now that was some communication
drink if you're confused Peter suddenly
747s Victoria you know one solid night
together I guess and suddenly he has all
the confidence in the world it's like I
have all the confidence in the world
with it right now is the plane flying
below me on the screen right now it
should be 747 starting to hate this
plane
[Music]
madness
you
I am in love with three woman right now
so Peter says he is in love with three
women what did you guys think of this
let me know in the comments below can
you be in love or three people at one
time
does Peter know what love is and are you
confused about who Peter should or will
pick in the end communicate to me about
it
Victoria returns to her health education
class and tells her peers that she and
Peter's fantasy suites date was
productive it was productive right yeah
definitely I was obviously a really
amusing way to communicate now it's time
for Madison and for the first part of
their date Madison and Peter are going
to climb the outside of a 77 storey
building so see it at the very top we
actually had the client ed it looks
quite stressful it could all come
crashing down and I was like feeling all
that energy you know like look where we
are on this building we're here Madison
says she's worried that she and Peter
aren't on the same page I'm nervous that
we're not on the exact same page right
now with everything yeah babe everything
that's worth it
it's gonna come with a fight and it's
gonna come with a circle she's talking
about climbing the outside of the
building and I got his eight shears for
every metaphorical thing she said you
know everything worthwhile is uphill
sometimes the wind is against you and
the world is against you but
once you get to the top and you see that
view it's all worth it
but I guess climbing the outside of a
building and realize that you're
potentially risking your life was the
kind of intense situation that Madison
needed to be able to communicate our
feelings that she's in love with Peter
the man that I've just realized that I'm
in love with oh wait she just said him
in her head not to him oh gosh am I
feeling like I feel like my vibe is
feeling angry isn't it I gotta I gotta
escape I'm just gonna dream from it
okay 747s Peter is feeling the ultimate
feelings of happiness the ultimate
feeling of happiness the best feelings
of his life like the best feeling I've
ever felt in my entire life he never
wants to let go I never want to let go
drink back at Girl Scout headquarters
Victoria has learned about Madison's non
ultimatum ultimatum how the conversation
was about her expectations for this week
and her expectations for him this week
what Victoria was relishing this wasn't
she I just felt like she was thinking
thank God someone else's Madison has
different Peter an ultimatum and I feel
like putting him in that position is so
unfair so Peter and Madison are sitting
down to dinner at this moment tell me
what you guys think because now we've
got to descend in madness this has been
on my mind since the night that he
brought it to me
she wouldn't be okay with me being
intimate with anyone else
Peter did seem to know that Madison at
least had a problem with the idea of him
sleeping with other people so she was
definitely testing him and what'd he do
is he also testing her and how she'd
respond so he tests so many hidden
agendas going up I made a comment to
myself now we're dropping bombs
Madison finally tells Peter that she's a
virgin I wanted to save myself a
marriage I respect the hell out of you
for being able to make that commitment
to yourself to save that for her
marriage and Peter says I respect that
but we're different in that regard
that's not me and we're different in
every garden please like I don't know if
you heard about some stuff in a windmill
with me that went down like a couple of
times yeah and you guys I know we all
see it right this is borderline exactly
what Luke P
did to Hanabi I don't sense as much
judgment from Madison and she hasn't
been treating Peter the way Luke Pete
treated Hanna but I still feel Peter
should be more upset than he is I
wouldn't be able to say us an engagement
and continuing to like move forward if
you have sup - it's the other woman I
mean she then says that she can't wrap
her mind around Peter proposing in a
week after being intimate with someone
else
I just can't like grab my mind around in
a week from now if you're down on one
knee in six days before that you were
except us on my own Madison I need you
to communicate with me on something have
you seen this show she starts talking
about how she would get frustrated that
Peter kissed other women no not okay
with the guy that
did kissing on the woman she said it
wasn't an ultimatum that it was Madison
Oh Madison Asst oh god I don't want to
feel like a bad person for like the
standards that I have I really need to
know why Madison came on the show in the
first place I do was she captivated by
Peter after seeing him on hanabi's
season and just had to power through the
parameters of the show and and just
really wanted him that badly I need a
reason people I have been to me I can't
lie to you about that
cheers to Peter for honest communication
he also tells Madison that honestly he
could see being with other people at the
end of this got into this week I could
see that with other people too we come
back from a commercial break and I just
want to give a shout out to the two
kangaroos looking on in the night as
Madison Christ like were they listening
they're like girl get in my pouch I
don't wanna get out of here you're like
do you want me to jump kick somebody for
you Oh Madison's crying in Peters crying
too and oh wow don't drink during this
sad shot of Peters face alone at the
table I don't like sad Peter it's not
sobbing barb you're home to us I still
don't like sad Peter
[Music]
unclear how long Madison's been back in
the outback with the wildlife but Peter
does finally go get her and Oh God drink
during the whole time that they're
standing so sadly with their heads
touching and they're like looking to
each other touching each other then
Peter says he can't lose her I can't
lose you
so sad not really touch to get my arms
out long enough what am i touching for
the upper shoulder okay and Peter's like
say something that's the end of the all
right everybody that's all we got but of
course next up is the women tell all
hosted by Chris Harrison Oh have you
been standing there this whole time yeah
you kind of loosen it I know well yes
I'm losing my mind and since we've given
you Chris Harrison plenty of shameless
plus I think it's time to grill are you
ready
Cheers cheers to a grilling he's a
walking brand everybody Chris Peter
dating a producer right now Julie is an
amazing talented producer far be it for
me to ruin anything towards the end of
the season but seems much ado about
nothing to me really yeah
well how would you list I just don't
know which is possible drink for Peter
yeah yeah Jennifer Barnes refurb on the
woman's a national treasure I know would
you say this is the wildest ending
there's ever been yeah going back to I
mean it's hard to say because the Jason
mesnick's of the world the re and even
Colton but this is up there who do you
plan to grill the most at the women tell
all
it's gonna be an interesting tell-all
because this group doesn't quite have
that sisterhood that a lot of them have
there's always the villain or the one
that's outspoken the most but it seems
to have been fractured so much why are
the final three living together during
fantasy suites we've never done it
before obviously this is a little
historical there's things we do as
producers on the show that will force
situations that need to be forced this
Madison relationship needed to come to a
head clearly there were things that
needed to be spoken up they're not good
at speaking
she put an ultimatum on the table which
by the way is fine if that's your faith
if that's your way of life that's fine I
know why is she on The Bachelor
bigger question why why why but that was
the reason we put them all together yes
it was awkward and yes we have never
done it before probably won't ever do it
again but this season it needed it
because Madison and Peter in that
situation really dictated it needed to
happen who will be our new bachelorette
it's a great question I can tell you
this we don't know yet the debate is
still raging on and it is a very strong
debate may be the strongest debate we
have had in many years what do you like
[Laughter]
[Music]
drink every time Chris Harrison dodges a
question leave your comments below
alright Chris Harrison thank you for
being here you can follow us both on
Twitter Instagram and we're both on the
app cameo Plus drinks Seagram's
games babe so your JC the guy who's been
relentlessly making fun of me for years
everybody you just jump them dance
you just walk through them are you
serious about it what no I'm looking for
the creamer honestly JC
because I'm a man of love this goes to
you JC for the best performance of
faking the Chris Harrison run and gate
open during Colton's season I accept
Lauren take a moment say your goodbyes
oh you did you you did it okay
this was a 200 ok alright JC got the
rose and Mike - Mike ston said Miss
maybe just make it work so she's making
it awkward I knew this is gonna be weird
when I asked her to leave okay bye
so JC hi works here Tucson yeah totally
[Music]
[Music]